alright let me do a little bookend this
is not a huge story by itself but it's
really funny to watch I refer to it
earlier check this out extremist
Republican Devin Nunez called Lieutenant
Colonel Alexander VIN man who was a key
witness yesterday in the Trump
impeachment hearings demin noon is
called a mister and he was quickly
corrected by the lieutenant colonel
Trump didn't like it Republicans are all
up in arms about this I love it take a
look at this mr. VIN Minh you testified
in your deposition that you did not know
the whistleblower remember exiled
Lieutenant Colonel vermin please
Lieutenant Colonel women you testified
in the deposition that you did not know
who the whistleblower was all right I do
not know who the whistleblower is that
is how is it what I love about this
story is that you can actually hear in
Devin new neces voice and see if you're
watching the video he's visibly
uncomfortable and shaken by this
correction from the lieutenant colonel
Trump criticized VIN Minh for this
disgraced ex New York City Police
Department officer Bernie Kerik blasted
VIN Minh for this I respect this and
I'll tell you why their entire strategy
is to discredit the witnesses assail
their character attack their credibility
and their credentials and whether they
even were in a position to know anything
that they're testifying about so as
funny and hilarious as it is to see
Devin Nunez get visibly nervous because
of this this actually relates to their
strategy this is the death of a thousand
cuts
oh you weren't on the call oh you're mr.
rather than the active duty member of
the military Lieutenant Colonel that my
party claims to support and respect and
defend an honor oh you didn't tell your
supervisor about this it's a thousand
little cuts because that's the only
strategy they can employ and Lieutenant
Colonel VIN Minh did the right thing and
it threw Devin Yunus off for a few
minutes good for him and by the way
again
for the party who claims to respect
veterans and treat them well this is an
active duty member of the military who
was blown up in 2004 in Iraq he's in
uniform testifying under oath and his
title is lieutenant colonel
it's on every TV screen it's on all of
their notes it's not mr. and Trump
complained about it who cares
nice job I loved seeing this make sure
that you're on the David Pakman show
newsletter sign up at david pakman.com
on black friday we will be emailing
everybody on our newsletter about a
massive membership special that is
upcoming sign up for the newsletter and
let me know what you think about mr. bin
Minh lieutenant-colonel vin Minh by
sending me a tweet at de Pakman I am
thrilled to tell you that today's
episode is sponsored in part by Blink
accom slash Pakman Blink astiz a really
unique service for your phone tablet and
web browser and it is incredibly useful
for people like me who love books and
learning but are busy blinka steaks the
best and most popular non-fiction books
and condenses them into 15-minute
audiobooks I'm sure that if you're like
me you have a very long list of books
that you've been meaning to read you
only have so many hours in the day and
that's why blink astiz so amazing they
take the most important information the
themes the insights from each book and
they distill it into a 15 minute audio
book that you can listen to in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blankets our audience can get a seven
day free trial by going to blink accom
slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I've put a link in the
description I have listened to blinka
spokes about economics about political
science about history about science so
many interesting things and after the
free trial if you like it you can
continue enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about five bucks a month
go to blink is calm slash Pakman that's
bli n ki st.com /p a que ma n